je voudrais sans sans revenir trop loin
dans l'histoire
revenir en 1961 avec la création la
création du CNES et dès ce moment-là je
crois que le général de Gaulle a tout de
suite eu une idée extrêmement claire sur
le fait qu'il fallait avoir un accès
autonome à l'espace pour garantir
l'autonomie stratégique nationale et
l'automobile stratégique européenne
derrière
l'exemple que que je voudrais simplement
reprendre c'est ce qui s'est passé donc
avec en 1973 le programme Ariane qui
débute il faut bien se rappeler quand
même que l'idée derrière c'est enfin ce
programme est arrivé à un moment où nous
avions un certain nombre de projets de
satellites qui étaient satellite
européen qui était bloquée parce qu'il
ne correspondait pas aux canons ou
souhait de notre partenaire majeur
d'hier comme aujourd'hui que sont que
sont les États-Unis et donc on ne
pouvait pas lancer les satellites qui
étaient qui étaient qui étaient au jeu
qui était qui était au cœur de la
stratégie européenne et donc le
programme Ariane était là avant tout
aussi pour répondre pour répondre à
cette question là je pense qu'il faut
tout en étant évidemment extrêmement
clair sur le fait que les États-Unis
sont aujourd'hui le partenaire numéro 1
de l'Europe spatiale et je crois qu'on
s'en réjouit tous je pense que ce
partenariat n'est pas du tout exclusif
d'une forme d'autonomie et d'une forme
de de voilà il faut que l'Europe
spatiale s'affirme et la puissance
nécessaire donc j'ai cité Ariane
évidemment au-delà d'Ariane dans ces
déclinaisons successives c'est aussi
évidemment plus récemment avec avec Vega
qui s'affirme comme comme un lanceur de
plus faible puissance cariane mais qui a
un lanceur qui aujourd'hui est un
lanceur efficace et qui nous permet de
compléter la panoplie la panoplie
européenne donc pour revenir simplement
à cette idée très simple je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de puissance
spatiale aujourd'hui dans le dans le
monde qui ne soit pas en même temps
capable d'avoir justement un accès à
l'espace et donc la question des la
question de l'accès et donc la question
des lanceurs reste au cœur reste au cœur
du sujet